this is the growing emergency on
america's border with mexico
the government has released these
pictures of its hastily set up
processing facilities
for unaccompanied children critics claim
they are more like jails
new arrivals are given basic health
checks
but it's clear they're living in
unsuitable and overcrowded conditions
with a constant flow of migrants making
their way to the border
the u.s is now on course for the worst
crisis
for 20 years
republicans accused president biden of
losing control
but immigration experts say the
situation is far more complex
i think that what's clear is that biden
president biden is committed to
allowing people to seek asylum as is
accorded in our law
and i guess that idea that there will be
a legal pathway for people fleeing
persecution to come to the country is a
change
is a remarkable change to the trump
administration what is apparent is that
border control is struggling to cope
and this issue is becoming a significant
problem for the administration
in these early days joe biden wanted the
focus to be on his
covid relief package and his vaccination
program
but the images of large numbers of
children in detention centers
is starting to detract from that agenda
what's happening
down on the border is becoming the first
crisis
of his presidency and the questions of
how to deal with this situation
just keep on coming what more can be
done sir
a lot more we're in the process of doing
it now including making sure that we
reestablish
what existed before which was they can
stay in place and make their case from
their home country
with numbers surging the
administration's been forced to publicly
state
the border is closed for now at least
though it hasn't slowed the flow of
children making the journey
hoping to be reunited with family
already in the united states
alex rossi sky news washington